[موسيقى]
الحياه مسلسل اثار جدل كبير جدا جدا
بسبب وجود اخطاء تاريخيه فيه
والاخطاء التاريخيه دي شويه صرفت النظر عن
النقد الفني
[موسيقى]
يمكن لان اللي فتحت الاخطاء التاريخيه دي
خليني اقول انه اخطاء فادحه مكنش
صحرات من العاملين في وصرف الملايين عليه
[موسيقى]
عندنا خطا اللي هو لقاء الامام الشافعي
وده خطا تاريخي يعني اللقاء الامام
الشافعي مع الخليفه المامون وهو بالمناسبه
لقاء متخيل تماما لم يحدث وهو من الاضافات
التي
لا يحق
للمبدع انه يضيفها لانهم ببساطه في مغالطه
تاريخيه الخطا الثاني انه الامام الشافعي
والامام
تكلموا باللهجه العاميه المصريه
طب هو كان في لهجه عاميه مصريه ده مشهد
متخيل تماما كان في اخطاء مذهبيه في صلاه
الامام الشافعي يعني مخلفه لما ذهبوا لم
يكن يصلي بهذه الطريقه
وايه اللي جوه الامام
لراهب مسيحي لعلاج زوجته وده لم يرد في اي
كتاب وبالتالي هو خيال محضر
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد تعمد للخطا
ولا يوجد تمرين مقصود لطريقه خاطئه مثلا
في صلاه الامام الشافعي لان الامر الحقيقه
اكتر ماساويه من فكره الخطا
هو ببساطه اهدار لقيمه الاتقان اهدار
لقيمه التدقيق والدقه في العمل لجوء
الاستسهال اللي ما بيحترمش لعقل المشاهد
ولا ثقافته الملاحظات الاخيره اللي هي
بالتحديد الحديث باللهجه العاميه المصريه
ولهوء الامام الشافعي اللي راهب لعلاج
زوجته
في ظني ان هي جزء من الرساله بس مش رساله
رساله اصحاب العمل نفسه اللي عايز يقولوا
فيها نسختهم من رساله الامام الشافعي
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن صناعه اعاده استنساخ التاريخ لكن
يمكن وهو ده اللي بيعمله مبدعى نموذج
متخيل لما يمكن ان تكون الامور عليه في
اللحظه اللي بيستعرضها
وبالتالي هو يحل له ما لا يحل المؤرخ يعني
ممكن يحذف يضيف يعدل حقه لكن التعديل ده
مشروب بالالتزام بالحدث التاريخي فهو
الثابت
طيب هو الحدث التاريخي ده بيتضمن التواريخ
والشخصيات فقط لا لانه بيشمل كمان تفاصيل
في التاريخ الاجتماعي لا يصح تغيرها لانه
تغيير ملامح المجتمع بمعنى يعني تغيير
الملابس
اضافه قيمه مجتمعيه حديثه للمجتمع في
اللحظه التاريخيه يعني ما ينفعش اضيف
عربيات مثلا في اللحظه في سنه 1998 هجريه
يعني